il va falloir travailler plus longtemps
c'est le sens de la réforme des
retraites qui s'engage les français
l'ont bien compris
ne serait ce qu'en raison de
l'augmentation de l'espérance de vie
mais où fixer la barre comment calculer
l'âge de la retraite à taux plein celle
qui permet à chaque français de partir
avec une retraite entière
deux options sont sur la table la
première option c'est de permettre aux
français de partir tous à l'âge de 64
ans 64 on devient l'âge pivot avec une
décote de 5% par an pour ceux qui
partent avant et une surcote de 5% par
an pour ceux qui partent
après c'est l'option qui a la préférence
de jean paul delevoye
mais le président de la république lors
de son allocution télévisée de biarritz
a mis sur la table une seconde option
celle de la durée de cotisation alors là
plus question de partir tous au même âge
chacun partira dès qu'il aura accumulé
un nombre minimal de trimestre une durée
de cotisation minimale 7 du real est
fixé aujourd'hui à 41 ans et demi et
elle doit passer à 43 ans d'ici 2035
c'est voter c'est dans la loi touraine
de 2014 alors le président n'a pas donné
de détails mais tout le monde a bien
compris qu'il faudrait probablement
augmenter s'est accéléré cette hausse de
la durée de cotisation et peut-être même
aller au delà des 43 ans cotisent et
encore davantage
alors ces deux options n'ont pas le même
impact pour tous les français pour faire
court la durée de cotisation bénéficient
plutôt à ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler tôt en revanche le pénalise
ceux qui font des études et donc les
cadres
si on prend un exemple simple un jeune
qui fait 5 ans d'études qui rentrent sur
le marché du travail à 23 ans il devra
attendre soixante six ans pour avoir ses
43 ans de cotisations et donc pour lui
bien sûr l'âge pivot à 64 ans est plus
avantageux je préfère qu'on trouve un
accord sur la durée de cotisation plutôt
que sur l'âge parce que si vous avez un
accord sur la durée de cotisation quand
vous rentrez tard dans la vie
professionnelle finissait plus tard mais
généralement c'est que vous êtes rentré
tard parce que vous avez fait des études
et quand vous commencez tôt cotisé
longtemps que vous partez plutôt ça me
semble plus juste
le président juge l'option de la durée
de cotisation plus juste mais cet
argument a étonné et cela pour trois
raisons d'abord un gouvernement qui a
engagé
fermement dans la lutte contre le
chômage il serait étonnant qu'il
pénalise ceux qui investissent dans la
formation qui font l'effort de se former
or on sait bien aujourd'hui que c'est le
manque de compétences qui explique le
très fort taux de chômage en france
deuxièmement la durée de cotisation
pénalise aussi les femmes
or le gouvernement a fait de l'équité et
de l'égalité hommes femmes songent faire
son cheval de bataille
les femmes ont généralement des durées
de cotisation moindre que celle des
hommes car elles ont des carrières plus
courtes et en raison de la maternité et
de l'éducation des enfants
enfin d'un point de vue strictement
financier
le levier de la durée de cotisation est
moins efficace que l'âge pivot pour
rétablir l'équilibré financier du
système dont on sait qu'il sera en
déficit dès 2022
alors pourquoi est-ce qu'ils emmanuel
macron a mis cette option sur la table
en fait c'est un geste d'ouverture vers
les syndicats qui sont tous hostiles aux
décalages au report de l'âge de départ
en retraite sans doute que la durée de
cotisation serait un levier moins
difficile à accepter pour faire passer
cette pilule amère que là que l'âge
pivot
on le voit emmanuel macron déstabilisé
par le mouvement des gilets jaunes
avance prudemment sur le terrain miné
des retraites les syndicats vont être
reçus à matignon les 5 et 6 septembre
mais déjà des mouvements de madiot et
des mouvements de mobilisation sont
prévues le 16 à l'appel le 7 septembre à
l'appel des professions libérales le 21
à l'appel de force ouvrière le 24 à
l'appel de la cgt
alors rien n'est tranché toutes les
options sont sur la table assure le
gouvernement
mais après dix-huit mois de concertation
il va falloir donner clairement la
couleur aux français entré dans le dur
et faire enfin des choix